Cool.
Um, today is technically a holiday, but
I said I'd stream for two weeks.
quite tired today. I figure we're going
to get some stuff done anyways.
Oops. Let me clean up the screen real
quick.
Oh, right. I forgot to clean that.
back. One last thing. Hang on, folks.
That's good enough, I think.
Yeah, we're good.
I'll switch this over.
Cool.
So, here's the plan for today. Um,
we pretty much just have to make sure I
didn't break anything with the optimizer
fixes.
Check the new version of protein.
And I think we're okay.
I think that's pretty much all we need
to do.
So, we're going to do shorter stream
today.
We're ahead of schedule.
Maybe we'll do a couple other things,
but I want to keep it focused on the new
update. I don't want to really branch
out or do anything else.
Uh
Let's go check our experiments first. I
did have um this nice little breakout
sweep.
What the heck happened here? Why is this
being weird?
Hello, Liberty.
And hey, Finn.
Uh, 5os needs to be out this summer.
Finn, the goal is pretty much to not
just keep putting more and more crap
into it. Um, I don't literally need to
have it released in two weeks. I just
want to have all the core research done
in two weeks,
but it'll be out this summer.
And if you want to play with it uh
during your internship, it will be
plenty stable by then as well.
Move this so I can actually see. Yeah,
there. Maybe like this.
What the [ __ ] is this?
All right, there we are.
billion selfplay.
Yeah,
Ah,
damn it.
All right, this is what we're going to
do.
I renamed some parameters is really
annoying.
Oh, yeah. Also, is this I forget if I'm
sweeping.
Okay. So, this is not sweeping
curriculum.
Yeah. So, this is actually this is a
good clean experiment.
sweep's not using the target metric.
Uh, that's really [ __ ] bad if that's
the case.
Did you PR something for that? Cuz
that's really [ __ ] bad.
Is that new in 40?
because we have active work that that
would impact in 3 0.
I would assume I introduced that in 40
by mistake.
Yeah,
that's RF. What?
actually that doesn't mess up anything
in Puffer 4 based on our current work.
It would mess stuff up if it's in three.
Okay, so this is we get to compare these
two
4.29
but then most of the sweep is slower.
Oh, because I ran the sweep on a
different box. I see.
8. Was this 56?
And then we got a 3.8576
mil.
What? We We got this 8614.6.
I think this is pretty reasonable,
right?
I don't see anything super broken.
Looks pretty close to comparable.
The main thing is that I need to test
protein. So, we can test protein based
on this. This is good enough.
It's in three as well. [ __ ]
February.
Okay. Yeah, that's really bad.
I'm uh I'm going to have to can you like
submit me a patch or something like or
something because that actually impacts
ongoing work in three. Luckily, it's
work from the last couple of days. Um
but it's very relevant to Puffer 5.
That's actually a very helpful catch.
Thank you.
I'd be kind of surprised if I [ __ ] that
up in three. I would not be surprised at
all if I didn't catch that in the for
Start.
Oh, wait. I do have this, don't I?
I have an extra box. I forgot about
that.
That's very nice, actually. I have an
extra box.
cuz uh unfortunately I somehow our
multiGPU box one of them is down
and um the person who's usually there to
reboot it has not replied to my messages
uh zero the one I was on there was a
problem on one of the GPUs Um, I
probably should have just disabled that
one GPU, but I rebooted it because it
always comes back after I reboot it. Um,
it's set up to do that and this time it
Wait. This is not a huge improvement at
all, is it?
Yeah, I I don't know why. Okay. So, this
is actually not a big deal then, is it?
Yeah. This is very stupid because uh
protein is based on this. I mean, carbs
is based on this. Protein is based on
carbs. And now this [ __ ] puts this
stupid thing back.
This is also not how you use um this is
not how you use sweeps either.
Okay. So, there's some ideas in here,
but this is not such a massive thing
that I need to be worried about this for
the time being.
Uh, this was Jess. Luke is the author of
Heavy Ball.
He made it seem like it was way
way way
better. This is like a very small
change.
Yeah, but this is still like
this is still not huge.
Okay, that actually saves me some time.
Um,
How frequent are the actions? Does it
matter if you just do one action per
turn?
You don't want to have you don't want to
have like repeated multi like you
probably just want the three actions
though. You probably don't want to swap
it across like you know just give it the
same thing several times over.
returns.
Yeah, I guess if you run the game, how
fast is it? Because I think the game
that that thing is based on, Jess, um
the game that thing is based on is kind
of like real timey. So depending on how
real time it is, it might not matter if
you only do one per turn.
live.
Stupid internet's just been awful the
last few days.
It just randomly cuts out like a couple
times an hour for a second or two.
Hello, welcome. Um, I'm just running
some tests on 2048 at the moment and
I pretty much just want to verify some
changes that I made.
We're also we have some other M's that
we need to start playing around with.
Oops. Let's go do something real quick.
I think we are going to spend the first
hour here just [ __ ] around with a
couple things here and then maybe we'll
also start on um
do we want to do inferno
or boxabon?
Where's Tim actually with boxabon?
Did he get me a PR?
Got this
and we got this.
Let us
You get the current 16 bits.
How's it been a good test for you for
stuff?
I guess I'll have to just play with it,
right? And run some experiments and see
if it's a nice test done for stuff.
We're looking for things where we can
really kind of show um the new
algorithms off
any reputable work and robust trading
agents.
Uh we do a little bit of that work. We
do a little bit of work in that space
professionally.
Details of that are not public.
Uh I'm trying to think if there's
anything open. Uh we do some stuff in
commerce that is open source with
archive.
Uh finance stuff other than us I don't
really know of. Maybe the big firms have
it, but I don't think there's really any
public stuff that makes sense at the
moment on that.
Fairly sparse. All right. Well, I'll
give that a try when it's ready.
Convert.
We also have a We have a whole bunch of
M's I need to just pull in for 50, don't
I?
Yeah, I don't know why it's all the
[ __ ] MPM packages.
Awful.
Okay. So, this the point of this is I
just want to see if this does way better
um before my optimizer changes.
We'll leave this running. And I've got
check billing plan. How do I [ __ ] How
do you log into this stupid thing?
Ah, there you go.
Uh,
yeah.
Probably not a great way to do that
authentication. Open AAI.
Okay.
what I wanted to do.
And hopefully this does better. We will
see.
And annoyingly, these experiments take
long enough that I will probably
I'm probably going to have to run a few
of these. Um, even though they take half
an hour each. We will see.
This might be getting better with this
one. We'll see.
I pretty much I just want to pull Tim's
changes into 50
and then uh update it to the state set
API. Make sure we don't break anything
and you start using his end to test 50.
This is quite promising.
anything important
any cool research I missed?
I saw the really cool object detection
stuff where a guy literally just
annotated two million things on his own.
Uh, he got this completely wrong. It's
re It's scientist and engineer, not
researcher and engineer. Researcher was
the correct one.
Research is the actual what you're
doing.
The Volo says he's pushing M's up
tonight, which will be very nice.
And then those will be all the M's that
we need
uh for puffer five.
Well, regardless of what people have
changed the word, like I don't care if
people have changed the [ __ ] word.
That's what it means.
I was talking to somebody earlier who
said foundation model to just mean
model.
to state set ready.
Yeah. So simple ends you can just have a
you can just get it converted if you
have it reference uh the existing
simpler ones. You do have to make sure
it doesn't screw stuff up.
But it's a very simple deterministic
like it's basically a change with no
ambiguity in it.
Um,
Liberty. I literally the only reason I
switched to Codeex is cuz I was like
marginally less annoyed about giving
OpenAI money than Anthropic. That's
literally it.
I mean the stuff I do is um
is much more niche, right? This is
research.
Like this is not always meant to be
particularly interesting or
entertaining, right?
Or even educational. All of that is
secondary to getting the research done.
at the moment. That means [ __ ] with a
bunch of M's, integrating some crap, and
running some very slow, tedious
experiments manually.
like there's probably not really going
to be any real programming happening
um
for a while until I finish core
experiments, right?
I'm glad to see that the um the protein
changes were not massive. And actually
somebody making that graph saved me a
lot of time in figuring that out because
I wouldn't have even seen the difference
um the way I would have done it
actually. Just one of the things I felt
like doing at some point was making like
um
who was it? Was it Anish or was it um
who submitted the whack-a-ole? But I
think it was a nish, right?
wanted to make like a better AIM trainer
style EN
and then use it to test the entity
encoder as well as continuous action
spaces.
We still don't have any solid on 65k.
Little concerning
Okay,
this is almost done.
It's very jumpy, isn't it?
If this gets like 16k versus if this
gets 14k, I'm going to have to do
different things.
It'll save me a lot of effort if this
just gets 16k.
We'll see.
I made some optimizer tweaks
that I thought should be quite safe.
Hello Tim. I am uh actually in the
process of incorporating your Boxabon
uh end of right now with setible state.
Uh I'm going to have this thing tested.
I'll clean it up a little bit and I will
be using this for 50 research. So, thank
you very much.
I see.
We'll do a diff obviously before we
merge this.
We'll make sure it's a minimal diff.
No, this is it's just pasting this isn't
just pasting the existing crap
um because it doesn't have access to a
direct editor for whatever dumb reason.
Don't worry, I'm going to just run a
diff versus the um the previous
obviously.
So, basically this is because you sent
your PR to 40. I'm just pulling it into
50 and then I'm going to have uh and
then I'm going to get the state sets on
it and make sure this is done correctly
and also test it versus the original so
it's not broken and stupid. And then I'm
going to run uh your config
on incremental
And then I'm going to compare it to the
50 algorithm.
That's the general idea.
Okay. So, [sighs]
Well, it's not expected that you find a
good config on um that incremental
problem with 40, right? Why would you
expect to Why would you expect to have
something good with that?
That's like stupid stupid sparse
exploration problem.
You probably will need five to solve
that.
buffer is magic, but there are
limitations to the wizardry.
It's actually kind of funny. So, for the
folks watching, um, the thing that I
expect to happen very soon with Puffer 5
and six is we're basically going to have
a lot of these really toy looking
problems where we're just solving
different versions of mazes and little
puzzles and things. And um, people
outside this base are going to just be
like, "Oh, yeah, whatever. This is
nothing." And then pretty much
overnight, Puffer is just gonna solve a
ton of unsolved, like actually crazy
hardl lookinging problems. And all the
people outside of this base are going to
go, well, what the heck? How where did
this come from? But for us, it's very
very expected. Um because essentially
all these little problems that we're
doing, they have onetoone mappings to
the core unsolved problems in RL and the
core algorithmic deficiencies that are
holding the field back.
Um so as soon as we have these working
like we pretty much should just be able
to hard solve a lot of stuff.
That's the expectation.
Because like mazes, right? Different
permutations of these mazes map to state
exploration and credit assignment
and they're very very robust tests of
these problems.
Um, and these problems show up in sort
of harder to see but core these problems
sort of limit your learning on other
more involved environments but in a way
that's a lot harder to disentangle from
everything else that's going on.
We have quite a lot of them, Jess. I
just have to merge them in.
I've actually even I've heard recently
of some pretty crazy stuff being done
with Puffer as well. Not yet public, but
soon.
and the object detection guy on Twitter.
If that's true, that's awesome.
Hello.
Morning
have plans.
I mean, our plans are pretty much
public.
It's just that like they require some
level of background to understand
lag spike. We back. Yeah, just lag
spike.
We're good.
What are we going after today? Nothing
much. Today's kind of a tired day. The
10K was just awful this morning. Just
kind of just tired. Um, but we're going
to pull in Boxabon.
Balo's got some other ends for us to
pull in as well. We're running some
confirmation checks on a few things that
I changed. Um, we're prepping some
sweeps
and we're pretty much just getting ready
to like fully test the new algorithm.
Uh, and we're going to essentially see
whether we need to change it at all,
there anything we need to modify with
it, or if it just works.
DM the plans.
What? Never upload all your plans into a
unlisted YouTube video.
Um,
maybe I'm definitely writing a blog
post.
I honestly don't even have concrete
plans yet for puffer six because it
depends on the algorithmic outcome of
five.
I like in my head, right? I know there's
one additional problem remaining we
haven't solved yet that I have a
collaboration on that's showing very
good results. Um I know there's some
system stuff that we have to do. There's
some general usability crap we have to
deal with and then there's some
benchmarking ends that we need,
but in my mind I I really don't think
we're that far away from having mature
robust always works RL.
I'm keeping the other exploration stuff
private for a few more days because it's
um still part of a collab. Um, that may
or may not even end up in five.
Wait, what do you mean the 4x
algorithmic deficiencies?
I don't remember have listing precisely
four.
I think I said the def.
No, I Yeah, that's not what I meant if I
did. It's not that there four
deficiencies.
There are a few deficiencies in puffer 4
that we still need to correct.
Um, that usually means that you have a
very screwy reward that's give like
putting a lot of pressure on it to not
do anything.
I can't speak to if you're using vanilla
PO, there's all sorts of crap that can
be wrong, but if you're using something
actually solid like puffer, well, I
mean, don't mean like puffer. Basically,
just puffer. There's really not an
alternative that's as stable as this.
But if you're doing it with Puffer and
you're getting some weird shortcuts,
almost every single time, it's cuz
you've set up the end of problem wrong.
What? Timmy, you put a 5-second config
in here.
Do you have a config that gets nonzero
PF, man? Like any sort of fastish config
that gets nonzero PF.
Like I wanted you to do the breakout one
just to test to make sure that it can be
fast. I didn't mean commit a break.
Commit the exact breakout config. If it
gets zero score, though,
I need something that learns something.
When I strip all of them out except
trading, I still get lazy policies.
Yeah, man. It's tough to know without
seeing your code. It's I will tell you
at least in Puffer, it's almost always
like sim engineering problem.
There are a few legitimate cases where
puffer can fail, but I mean pretty much
every single time people tell me stuff
like this, they've done something screwy
with the sim.
The 401 is probably the best.
Hang on.
Difficulty. So I keep the end here,
right?
And then
I do this crap.
like this.
Good to hear. Yeah. I mean, like a year
ago, right, there's all sorts of stuff
it could have been, but now our RL is
just pretty solid.
Oh, that's not bad. Six minutes. It's
already learning a little bit.
Yeah, we can do this.
Yeah, I remember that, Jess. That was
like
everybody got one shot by that crap for
years until there was a paper that
basically showed that they don't exist.
This was like 2016ish, I think.
And then it took a few years for
everybody to stop making up that
[ __ ] but it was just it was pretty
much the RL version of like um
of like oh bad ju guu or whatever.
It's like astrology for ML people.
They just use that as the reason
whenever anything didn't work.
I know Liberty.
I use it sometimes.
I find it kind of clunky though.
I mean, most of the like the model not
learning what you want is you didn't
actually specify what you wanted the way
you thought you did.
Like I said, there are few there couple
problems still left with puffer, but if
you've actually run a hyper pram sweep
and your end is well specified,
pretty damn good.
Uh,
this is five levels, Tim, right? And
nothing solves all five.
This is like the incremental one.
What the heck class was that? Jess, do
you have a class on phrasing wish wishes
for malevolent genius?
Nothing makes a dent on level three.
I see.
So, basically, this is going to get to
actually, why is it scaled like this?
Shouldn't this Perf number be 04?
Why does it have an episode return of
2.3?
Oh, is Perf giving it partial credit for
targets hit or something?
You have a 10 trillion run. Jesus. Well,
so if I just can solve this instantly,
it'll be very impressive, right?
4050 is hardcording. Okay, that's really
good news, Arch. Thank you very much.
That actually helps me a ton. If you'd
like to set us a PR for four uh for four
or five um even four actually we should
probably just backport that would be
awesome. Heck you can PR to both if you
want.
That's very useful.
I can kill this cuz this is all it's
going to do.
And then what we're going to do here
this. So we're going to take
we're going to take these params.
Uh
yeah, we're going to take these
parameters here.
I'm going to stick these down here.
[snorts]
Does anybody see anything wrong with
this?
They're like a weird new line somewhere.
If this stays on zero score, it's just
bad hypers. We'll see.
[laughter]
That's funny.
That's funny as [ __ ]
Yeah.
Can we get usable internet for once?
Jeez.
I think we're back.
Stupid though, man.
So annoying.
lot of streams due to super. Hey. Oh,
that's a nish. My bad. Um,
yeah, it's going well. 5 is going quite
well. We're still testing out the core
algorithm. We've got some things to uh
to evaluate. Still,
I'm playing around with Boxabon. I'm
playing around with a few small
optimizer tweaks.
We definitely need to see more like we
need to see this go on more problems.
Please go on to for a blackboard
lecture.
Oh jeez. I'd have to man I'd have to
like actually remember how to write on a
blackboard.
He messaged me one time a long time ago
or something and then I think that like
dropped off. I don't know.
Dude, what is wrong with the [ __ ]
internet today? Holy crap.
Like what is wrong with the internet,
Dream did not lag on my end.
Hopefully, it's buffering something then
because like I'm very consistently
seeing drop frames for a couple seconds
every 10 minutes.
I'm a little disappointed that this
doesn't just solve right out of the box.
Uh Tim, can I start it from level three
somehow?
Like is there a way I can start from
level three?
do a PhD under. You realize I'm not a
professor, right? I can't give PhDs out.
You can basically learn all the stuff um
from here without even having to do all
the academic [ __ ] though.
Uh,
so Tim, what does it do?
Um,
does that start you on
does that give you two levels or does
that start you on.
Well, it was set to diff five. What does
that do?
Oh,
then that's not what I wanted. Wait,
incremental is diff five.
int r co-f this is the reward shaping
right
so if I do Yes.
So what happens on medium
um what happens on medium is you
literally never solve a puzzle,
right?
Well, I wasn't checking if it's working
worse, man. It looks like you literally
solve zero puzzles.
I've not seen score go above zero ever.
Well, I guess three, but you're not
going to get good SPS on like garbage
hardware.
You can go rent a $300 GPU off a vast
for like 5 cents an hour with Puffer 4
and it'll be way faster than your Mac.
It's just not serious hardware.
I do see this episode length. I see
episode length dip a little bit every so
often. Does this mean it's getting a
solve?
I used to get 800k SPS on M3
max.
Recommend against getting into academia.
I only recommend people do PhDs who know
that they want to do PhDs. I don't ever
suggest anybody who's not sure if they
want to get a PhD to get a PhD.
Getting one random solve. Then why
doesn't score go up?
Why doesn't score go up, Tim? Cuz one
random solve should be enough for it to
learn things on should be enough for it
to learn something.
Yeah, I'm I'm not seeing ever it ever
solve.
So, we can't learn from literally no
signal.
I can try one map, but I doubt that
that's the issue, right?
Oh, there's no setting for the number of
maps here, dude.
Oh, wait. No, I'm dumb.
I'm dumb. Where are the maps?
Uh, there actually is not a map setting.
Is it really that hard to solve like a
single medium?
Damn. There is actually a gap here,
isn't there?
Yeah, but like we literally just need
one solve, Tim. Like it needs to solve
one map once and then Puffer can learn.
with eight actions.
Well, Kvert, if you can never random, so
with the current Puffer 5 algorithm, you
have to at least be able to get a signal
once.
So, if it's so sparse that you can never
get any signal, then you can't learn
anything.
There's something separate I'm working
on for that.
But for now, you need to actually
you need to solve something.
Hello Val, welcome.
Just testing some Puffer 5 things.
Well, that doesn't help convert. Like if
you started at level five,
like if you start it at five and you run
it and it can never get any reward on
five, right?
Yeah, Volo, if you get me an Inferno PR
with um like to five,
I'd be very happy to start playing with
it.
Be nice.
Well, we're looking like we're getting
close to the same performance as the
reward shaped one without the reward
shaping.
That's cool.
I don't know if you already had this,
but yeah, look at this.
We're going to solve um the score two
without shaping.
Doesn't look like it's done learning.
Uh yeah, but it would need to get it
would need to get a lucky solve on like
the third level or whatever, wouldn't
it?
I'll try something else here. We'll go
like this.
So, all we need is I just need signal
once, Tim.
Maybe a few times, but like it's not
buffer should be very good, especially
on like a static setup.
It should be very very good if you just
give it a little signal.
We'll see.
Okay, so to summarize for folks, this
window here, we are running some
ablations on some small optimizer tweaks
that I made. Um, the window on the
right, we are running Tim's Soabon
environment and we are integrating state
sets and we're seeing if we can get any
signs of life there. And then over off
on the other monitor with Discord, uh,
I'm waiting on Volo.
Uh, once I'm done with this, Volo will
probably have a PR up for Inferno.
Inferno is another nice sparse
exploration task for us to play with.
So, we'll see if that works.
solving most of the level below. It
takes a bit for it to start learning the
next. It hits a new level threshold
where it's solving most of it takes a
bit for it to start learning the next.
Uh, with Puffer 5, it shouldn't, Tim,
like in the sense of basically when it
hits a new level and it happens to solve
it once, that's enough for it to start
learning even if it's not consistently
solving the previous level Yeah.
What else do we have to do in the
meanwhile?
Can check uh what's going on lately with
PRs
That's hilarious. Great.
Um, do we have a ban
lock user? That looks good.
Uh, report content. Can we do this?
Oh, this doesn't even link you. That's
annoying. Shitty form.
Block it.
I'm not reading this. Holy LLM bet. Plus
400 lines to Yeah, I'm not reading this.
What the [ __ ]
Hello, welcome.
Aurora Impel was uh we merged this in
already.
Oh, BF-16. Thank you, Spencer. I wanted
this.
File changes. Source.
this is fine.
This is fine. Thank you.
Uh, this is unfortunate.
We still don't solve.
Uh, let me try one other.
So, I don't think that um I don't think
you actually get any random solves with
this. So, I would be surprised if you
do get any signal out of this.
I've been told that this is good. Arches
PR is good here.
I've been I've already been told this is
good and this works.
Oh, this is a lot. Uh, no, actually this
is fine, isn't it?
Okay, this is not an insta merge. This I
have I will get this in, but I have to
review this more. I'm not doing other
stuff
that will take some dedicated effort to
get in.
Um, I I forget how the moderator
positions work, but like sure,
that's actually a nice little
integration. I'm going to have to look
at it more when I do that.
Okay, this is what we need. This Yeah,
we have some good PRs open here.
Have some very useful PRs open.
And this I already merged manually. So
yeah, I have good PRs open till do.
What do we have here? Zeros, right?
So hang on. Wait. Tim has said that you
can technically get
Tim has told me you can technically get
a solve
on the third level of the incremental
difficulty.
I'm trying to think if that helps or
hurts,
I guess. Let me try let me try that real
quick.
That's actually a fine thing to test,
I'd say.
Let's do this and this with our state
sets.
Maybe that's enough sparity. I mean,
enough sparity reduction.
Yeah, I think that's probably the case,
Tim.
The problem is, at least with the
current algorithm, you need to solve it
randomly at least once.
And like honestly I don't even think
there is a reasonable
I don't think there is a reasonable
algorithm
uh that will solve this
from scratch
because even if you do state exploration
like every configuration of boxes is a
separate state. So, you have a [ __ ] ton
of states.
There's no way to link box on target
equal good. I guess you do need the
intermediates maybe.
I mean, so's an interesting problem for
those reasons, though.
Let me work on coverage. Uh it would
help certain mazes, Jess, but boxabana
is tough like the soaban thing cuz
There's not really a good measure of
progress in some sense.
I think we might have to slightly
reformulate one of the rewards and then
maybe we can do it.
Tim is incremental like a fixed set of
five mazes or is it a random difficulty
maze
for each like size or whatever.
You can't reliably detect if it's stuck,
bro.
There's no real like there's no
reasonable way to detect that.
I have a couple ideas if I'm allowed to
screw with that reward a little bit.
collects a random maze for the
difficulty is on. Okay, that's better.
So, in fact, I don't think then we even
need to do
so difficulty two. So, wait, the mazes
that it's getting stuck on here are the
same as the mazes when you set
difficulty to two, right? Uh Tim,
is that correct?
But can you just confirm so that the
mazes it's getting stuck on the level
here like it's not solving the mazes
that are the same as the one. Okay. So
we can just set difficulty too. Then
after this we'll set difficulty to two.
Yeah, this is kind of just mazes but way
harder.
Yeah, I need to look at your reward.
I'll do that in a second. Actually, can
I just like
Yeah, I have a way I can I have
something I want to try with this.
Let me commit this current thing first.
That was a long one.
Why do we pay for this crap again?
Stupid internet.
Okay, that's good.
Now what we do?
I really got to figure out this internet
crap.
I don't know why it keeps chopping up my
streams. It's messing with the viewer
experience. I know. I'm in California
and it's just always been crap. I guess
I could switch providers.
Most expensive goddamn state can't even
have stable internet.
It's not in five yet, Jess.
It like it will take me a bit of work to
merge.
It touches some stuff that I have to
like look at.
That's funny as hell.
They have four hours. Yep. Cool.
I want to see if this just immediately
solves or not.
So, let me explain what's happening over
here with these experiments. Um, I made
several optimizer changes
and you know, you can't like really
rerun all the experiments
for changing a couple small things with
the optimizer.
Side monitor update. That's funny. 200
million uh mining XP.
Uh,
this is on leagues just been sitting
there for the last two weeks.
Um, let me explain. they they optimizer
stuff. So
um we added we added polar express which
is a new method of orthogonalizing
matrices
for the gradients that is that is
supposed to be a strict upgrade to muon.
We changed the way that we compute uh
the slices of mat of like the weights to
orthogonalize for mining. That should be
a straight upgrade.
There was also a small change with
learning rate. That should be a straight
upgrade. And then the one thing that was
sketchy is we pulled in one change from
the Aurora optimizer.
And it seems that there's a perf
regression, though it could just be
noise.
I'm isolating that right here. Running
the baseline, the new thing, and then
the new thing without Aurora.
Okay, that's not super useful data, is
it?
[ __ ]
Well, I guess we're just going to have
to trust the sweep on breakout.
Cuz this is not super useful
information.
Yes, you technically do, Tim. But like
this was not this was not like a change
on the level of replace Adam with Muon.
This was a couple very small numerical
changes that are very well motivated and
should just be strictly good. They can
technically shift hypers a little bit.
I suppose I could now go test um maybe I
should just run breakout sweep again
with this
We'll just compare breakout with and
without this Aurora change.
That could mess with breakout. Yeah. So,
we'll have to leave this. We'll let this
run.
Let it do this. And we're going to try
Boxabon.
What's puffer about? Ultra high
performance reinforcement learning.
We do infrastructure, high perf
simulation or algorithmic research. The
works
all open source. We have the fastest
tools in existence in this space.
Yeah, I you know, I think you're going
to see more crazy [ __ ] like that.
This was kind of the um the fireball
article I wrote.
Like sufficiently good RL is going to
find some [ __ ] that just seems
impossible.
Oops. This is the incremental one.
All right, we'll see what this learns.
since this is a random selection of
puzzles. I expect this to do better.
We'll see.
Um, I mean it's a hard problem, Tim.
It kind of depends. I guess what you
could say is that I'm seeing whether it
makes sense for it to be able to learn
in six minutes right now.
I will say this is an end where if our
state sets work, it would result in
probably a very different config
from what you have now.
I want to see if this works. And then I
want to see about the other maps if that
works.
I have a feeling this could fix it.
I don't like to spend too much of my
time just like screwing around with
things, but occasionally I do just fix
stuff by screwing around with it like
this.
If this works, I'm going to be so mad.
But like, dude, this is this is the type
of thing I do this with everybody.
Ask Spencer the amount of times I've
done just like infuriating [ __ ] and made
something work in 10 minutes that he's
been working on for hours.
I do expect, by the way, that this will
get stuck on a few of the maps.
But can we just break this 20 threshold?
Maybe
if it doesn't work here, it might still
work
on the other one, but it's less likely.
also. Hang on.
Might need to be a little more
aggressive with this
because
No, wait. Huh?
Okay. No, this is correct. Yeah, this is
correct.
This decay factor might have to go up.
I'll play with that next. Well, I'll
play with the other map and then I'll
play with the decay factor.
Yeah. See, this is nice and stable and
it still has some entropy left. It's
just not ever seeing
it's just not ever seeing success on uh
the third level.
Gamma since you're restoring to a state.
Gamma is computed over segments and then
we're storing to a state and then
computing a full segment. So it works
the same way it always has.
No Tim, it's not solving any twos.
That's the problem. If it were solving
any twos, then Puffer would be able to
solve more. Oh, there it is. Now it's
solving twos. It just got one.
It's only got 48 seconds left in the
learning,
but that was it right there. It just got
the signal.
It will start learning from here if it
were given a little more time.
Okay. So,
we can play with this. I want to try
this on
I want to try this on just the two
difficulty because it might be faster.
And while this is running, I'm going to
look at Volo's thing.
What did I do? I screwed with your
rewards.
I made it so that you get a instead of
getting a reward the first time you move
a box onto a target, you uh you get a
reward any time a box goes onto a target
and then you get the same reward but
negative when a box goes off the target.
Oh yeah. Do I have your end of merged
into puffer at all? Actually, right now.
Wait, how were we doing this before? Val
did um
this is nice though.
Jesus Christ, man. It keeps getting
bigger.
like does it make sense? Should we start
working off of um should we just have
this in puffer now main? Is it better?
Yeah, I was pulling from your fork
before.
Does uh does it make sense to just start
upsource like up does it make stuff to
just start upstreaming things to Puffer
now?
You think stuff is like it's mature and
stable enough that we should just have
it in Puffer or am I going to get like a
50k line PR every week?
makes sense at this point. Okay, we'll
upstream it.
also um put it back if you'd prefer
10k
We're'll merge this and this will
motivate John to get us fight cave and
PR in as well. And then we'll have lots
of cool Ms to play with. It'll be great.
yeah, Volo, I'll merge this. But this is
the one thing I found so far that's a
little annoying.
I don't like you should not have to be
changing.
Wait, what is this? Dude, you don't need
this.
Yeah. What? Like what is all of this
Volo?
Like this is explicitly not what we were
doing with Puffer 5. This is the shitty
like featurized representation thing.
Yeah.
And you're [ __ ] with this as well.
What? Why is it freeing all my [ __ ] as
well?
Yeah, whatever model you're using [ __ ]
with stuff it shouldn't have [ __ ]
with. Volo
like the stuff in curriculum, all the
stuff in source should not have had to
have been [ __ ] with
this. Like made changes to my This made
changes to the core puffer.
This is fine. Wait, no, this isn't here.
This doesn't belong here either.
Yeah, this like this thing basically
didn't understand the difference with
five and just [ __ ] a bunch of my stuff
up. Um, yeah, this is a mess.
The [ __ ]
If you can just go look at like the
build file and the source files, it's
not that much code. It's like a few
hundred lines, but it's like completely
[ __ ] with a lot of our internals for
some reason. Just don't have that in
here. And then I can merge this whole
thing and we can start playing with it
and we'll be good.
I had to scroll through 80 some odd
files to find that by the way.
So yeah, just careful there.
Uh, okay. Look, non-zero score.
This is what we wanted. Non-zero score.
I do really want to have the inferno end
in here. Like I'm super excited for this
end, but it can't just break the rest of
the core in the process.
All right, I'm going to let this run.
I'm going to take a few minutes break
here. Um, I'm going to go grab my
vitamins and do a couple things
and then I will be back. Hopefully we'll
see if we can figure some stuff out with
Boxabon and we will proceed from there.
Uh yeah, before I take a quick break,
for anybody new around here, um if you
want to support my work for absolutely
free, I stream all of this dev and
research live most days. Just puffer.ai
star the repo on GitHub. That's it. It
really, really helps. Um, it basically
helps companies see my stuff and hire us
without me having to go spend my time
advertising. So, I get to spend more of
my time here doing Dev Live. If you want
to get involved with this, join the
Discord. It's all open source. We have
lots of contributors, including
relatively new people learning very
quickly. And all my educational stuff is
on X. You can follow that there. I will
be right back. And I guess I'll leave
I'll just leave this screen up and we'll
see if anything gets there. See you.
All right. [sighs and gasps]
Damn. Still still not uh not solved,
huh?
Um,
I do promotions when uh I see there are
a bunch of people watching and I'm about
to take a break.
Stupid thing, man.
Stupid internet.
All right. Uh, let's figure this [ __ ]
out. show.
You know, the maze one is really weird
though, isn't it?
I'm going to try this.
Um, I really don't have much hope for
this one, though.
In fact, I'm just going to put it here
for now because I really don't have much
hope for these params.
But I think it is worth trying this
briefly.
We need more than a 0002 signal um to
run sweeps on, I'd say. So, it's worth
like playing with this a little bit. And
this would also just be a such a nice
environment to validate stuff on as
well.
If we get stuff working on Soabon, that
would be
that'd be
I mean, the internet DC is like every
few minutes. It's like ridiculous.
Well, I suppose we'll see from this one
now.
Uh, that's not enough runs. Did this
fail?
Huh?
It's just taking forever for some
Huh? It's just taking forever for some reason. That's weird.
mass message didn't go through. Yeah, I
need some messages. If you don't see
your message up there, I'm not seeing
it.
I think we do want to play with
Yeah, I think we get rid of this
negative one reward.
He snapped out of his.
I don't think he ever got LM psychosis.
I think that guy's kind of just zany to
begin with. He's not like gigalmilled at
all. I don't think
I think he's just mad that a bunch I
think he's just basically mad that a
bunch of shitty like h like tech
Hollywood wannabes are perverting uh all
the stuff that he spent his life
building.
Now I can appreciate that.
It'd be so dumb if this config were the
one to solve. I'd highly doubt it, but
I'll try a couple other small things
here as well.
This might just have to be swept.
It's annoying though because I don't
have my tiny box.
Um, unless I have, let me see. I asked
to have it rebooted
and nope, it has not been rebooted.
Annoying.
Well, it's a holiday weekend. They're
probably just not there.
It is learning something here. You can
see it right. This is way way higher
than the random solve rate,
but just barely.
Okay, we're going to go back to the
original one and I'm going to get rid of
this negative one reward. It's probably
creating some dumb spurious
uh spurious correlations
unit test in the PR or remove them.
Uh
if you want to include them, I would say
stick them in the end of source. Don't
stick them in our top level tests.
You can like go stick a test directory
or like whatever in or just a file in uh
in your like ocean slash whatever end.
That's fine. I mostly just want to keep
this code for all the M separate from
the core of Puffer
Pathy joining Enthropic. It's been
beaten to death already.
I don't know. It's whatever man.
Ocean M.
Yeah, that's fine, man. You can just do
that. That's fine.
Okay, so this is slightly worse.
It's interesting that this works at all
though with this low prioritization
coefficient.
I think there is something here, right?
Because this,
let me just double check. I want to see
if this works at all without state sets.
If this works at all without state sets,
then I'm kind of just being a goober
here.
we had that level of performance without
state sets.
H
with defaults.
Yeah, you should really get a lot more
out of state sets.
We'll have to double check. I want to
see if the current version does it.
And we can also try to take out the dumb
um there's one reward I want to remove.
So, we'll just chill and do some
experiments.
Not that fast, though.
Nobody has intuition about how the
hypers work. You think you do and then
you get some crazy ass hypers that make
no sense and do better.
That's unfortunately how it is for now.
It's one of the things I want to uh
address.
We don't really know, Tim.
Um,
it should Well, I think on the maze end
that we had, it was the case that we
kind of just introduced something and it
worked. at
least reasonably well.
I mean, we really should just be able to
set
I'm going to try something after this.
Yeah. See, that's weird.
It actually does kind of learn on its
own a little bit.
I also wonder if it'll work better with
um local obs.
though. The whole thing is small enough
to just do globally.
We'll play around with a few things to
start. Yeah. So, this is without state
sets. It's actually fine.
State sets should really be doing more.
I mean, the thing is we already have
confirmation on the really, really hard
end. So,
it makes sense already.
LM people, stop talking about RL. You
have no idea what you're doing.
All right, so this is ridiculous. So
this is 0.006 with no state sets.
Best of n rollouts. Are they something
you do? No, that's what you do when you
have a stupid problem and you can't use
a real algorithm.
You don't do that when you're not
training a stupid language model cuz
it's slow as [ __ ] It's a great way to
burn money. If you want to light money
on fire though, you could just send it
on over instead.
Yeah, that's you muting the stream. My
audio is fine.
All right, so the state sets actually
hurt here. So that means that we just
have probably horrible settings for
them. Um I Let's play with the base form
of this problem a little bit first and
then we'll try the state sets again.
That'll probably be better.
many runs on parallel and pick the best
guys.
No,
there's literally so there's literally
there is already something in Puffer Lib
that does an infinitely better version
of that for you automatically.
The best of end people, this is just
like stupid LLM horseshit. Their
algorithms suck and the way that they
have that problem set up forces them to
use the worst algorithms you've ever
seen and then they just scale up massive
massive amounts of compute and burn
money until it works. That's how LLMs
work. Like it doesn't make sense to take
any inspiration from the stuff that the
LM people are doing in RL because the
stuff that they're doing is just [ __ ]
stupid because of how constrained their
problem is.
Like we have way way way way more
powerful algorithms than the LLM bros
will ever have.
Which is why we can do stuff like learn
on one GPU in seconds.
cuz the way that the LM work, they're
basically like they're taking actions in
tokens.
Um, well, it's either you look at them
as taking an action per token, which is
just ridiculous credit assignment, or
you look at it as actions with a just
huge, ridiculously big action space.
It's a mess. Either way,
I also really haven't thought too much
about about them to be honest. I really
just don't care about the LMRL crap
going on.
I mean either way Jess like it seems
pretty clear at this point that
compression type objective so any like
generative modeling type objective it's
just ridiculously compute hungry
and it doesn't seem likely that there's
going to be a way to just do it but way
faster
whereas With RL, it was never really
like flop hungry. It was just dog [ __ ]
engineering.
Uh, I doubt he's not going to be doing
any of the type of stuff I am, man.
I still have a huge amount of respect
for um
for Ilia.
I'll get those later.
Stupidex DM system.
Yeah, that's kind of the thing, Jess.
He's always trying to do out there
stuff. It's good. Where do you think RL
will be in a few years? Stable, mature
tech that's solving a lot of actual
problems
with Puffer Live doing a lot of them.
What about makes box? So, Boxabon is
just Soaban. You can go look up Soabon,
play it online or whatever. Um, and just
think about trying to randomly stumble
into solutions on that task and you'll
see why it's hard.
It's very hard to get any initial
learning signal.
I think Ilia's happy just being
completely unbothered doing his stuff.
Uh, I think this helped a little bit
actually just removing that extraneous
reward.
Yeah, Tim, this is not the type of end
where you need a negative reward on um
terminal.
Yeah, sure, Tim. This enemy is good if
you take out the dumb bits. But that
happens all the time, man.
If I can just get this to be like decent
enough. I'm trying like look, if I can
just get one good state set experiment
on this,
I just need like an actual hard high TR
like high confidence env where we kind
of demonstrate set date sets and we sort
of figure out the hypers a little bit
more
and maybe we can tune the algorithm a
little bit and we'll be good. And this
puffer five
or this did help though. This is now
plus I don't know plus 50% perf.
But we got some from changing the
rewards
and then from this.
And now 1%.
This is now within a range of what I
think we should be able to do well with
state sets.
It should help, right? Right. So, if it
doesn't help, something's song.
a specific part of the map.
And that is why we like games because
you don't [ __ ] things up like that as
readily.
I'm going to do something you should
never do
which is just guessing hyperparameters.
There's
Oh yeah, Ra is great man.
Ray is just the best.
We are a um top sponsor
of the project.
What am I working on? I am currently
doing uh soabon
and I'm trying to see if the new puffer
5 state setting algorithm
uh gives us a meaningful bump in
performance on this problem. It really
really should.
I have not seen it help yet,
which makes me a little bit suspicious
about our implementation.
At the point that it would be very
shocking if this doesn't work and it's
not like some just implementation quirk.
Okay. Hypothesis here.
Maybe the boxabun levels have less
reusable structure across them than
mazes.
So
you don't want too much of your data.
You don't want too much of your data to
come from
curriculum potentially cuz you warp
everything towards like two levels.
Remove the BS. I will review your PR
Okay,
cool.
big PR. This is the largest PR ever
merged. That's actually 61K lines of
code. Um, obviously not to Puffer Core.
Puffer Core has zero lines of code
change here. It's all the N
Oh, this is cool.
Um,
six.
Not really helping though.
Actually, is it on?
I wouldn't be surprised if it's
literally not on.
on the size of puffer
so I can write a community note.
M's are not included in the minimal
source code count.
Obviously, if we're going to just accept
whatever ends,
like the point is that the core is tiny.
Yeah. So, this is maybe a little better
than before, but about the same.
It should be a massive difference either
way, though, which is the odd thing. I'm
going to be able to play with this very
soon, and that's exciting to me.
I actually think that we should at least
get some signs of of life on um Soaban
though
before I try this on inferno. So it's
now it's merged in. But we should get
some signs of life
here. I'll let this go look for idiot
like failed modes first
and then uh we'll see.
We'll see what's next cuz it's really
not making any difference in
performance. And that's odd.
That's very odd.
We're alive.
And we're alive.
I guess. Let me go run some tests on the
maze, maybe.
Yeah, let me go run a couple quick tests
on Maze
Welcome everybody.
Uh to people who just got here, this is
one sec.
We're currently just running some
experiments on the new Puffer 5
algorithm, which is a form of explicit
curriculum learning. It uses the ability
to set the state of the simulator to any
previously seen state, which is actually
a very, very easy thing for us to add in
to pretty much anything.
Um, and I'm validating some of our
previous maze results because we have
one what should be a very good test
environment where we had very conclusive
results. unless I just miss something.
But they're not transferring well to
another end that should be very similar.
And uh that's not a thing that happens
in Puffer. Like in Puffer, our results
are very very consistent. So I'm trying
to figure out what's going on here.
And for anybody new, please do start
puffer on GitHub. It does help us out a
lot. Feed the puffer a star.
How's it been doing lately?
I'm letting this run basically to just
make sure that um we don't learn
anything without state sets.
If we do learn something without state
sets, I'll be shocked because there's no
way you learn a 2450 horizon problem
like this. Full sparsity, by the way, uh
without state sets. There's just no way.
I mean, if you do, the conclusion would
be that Puffer 4 is already just so good
that it kind of like hides the problem
complexity, I guess, but I I don't
believe that.
Yeah. So, these like little
There's no way, right?
I literally swept this as well
and I couldn't find baseline that did
did anything.
Wait, maybe I think the sweep was like
06.
I mean, it could learn like something as
basic as a directional bias maybe with
those few samples. Pulse
kind of. Yeah, Tim. I mean, this is only
121 million steps, though.
Well, no, you will get random solves,
but actually you can see it's not
consistent.
Stupid OBS. All right, we're back. Yes,
you can see it's not consistent, right?
Like it it started getting a little bit
of the signal and it failed to latch on.
I think this is acceptable.
I'm going to run the uh the previous
solve one more time
and we'll try this on
and soabon again.
So that is
like 0.1% of episodes
right
and now with this
watch the difference with puffer five
this should be a very convincing result
right you'll see the difference
immediately
watch this it takes it a few million
steps to get reward reward board is like
1 in 10 million by random chance.
60% chance to have seen it by right
now. So that's only 60% chance to have
seen it once.
You'll probably see it by 20 mil, maybe
30.
If it doesn't get it, something's been
broken because this worked before.
But I think we're just getting unlucky.
There you go. Now it'll solve.
You got the reward once right there.
And there you Yeah, there it is again.
And
hang on.
There you go. So now you'll see that
it's going up consistently.
So basically the data from that one
lucky trial got into the buffer. It got
replayed a bunch of times
and then it latches on to that
consistently.
So, it literally took 30 million steps
for it to get the reward once.
And then from that singular lucky trial,
we learned
mazes are random. Yes,
they're technically sampled from a set
of about 8,000.
And we should learn consistently from
here.
So that shows you the difference right
with puffer five. So why does it not
work on so
Oh, it's a very different problem, Tim.
But like the stuff is powerful enough
that I should see something, right?
Should see some signs of life.
Look at this. 32%. So, yeah, this works.
And this actually can get up to like 70
or 80 depending on the run.
It's spamming my [ __ ] post with all
these streams though. Every time the
internet blips
dude. What is wrong with this, man? Like
the last couple days, the internet's
just been borderline unusable
It is somewhat odd to me.
We haven't seen a single configuration
that vastly improves on state sets, huh?
For this problem,
I mean, I suppose we just will commit
the endixes.
Right. We will commit up the end fixes
and we'll have to just run a sweep on
this.
I guess I could try to set one up on
vast.
Is that a reasonable idea?
My box is still going to be down for the
rest of the day, I imagine, right?
Yeah, it might not even come back.
No, I'm in Palo Alto for a summer.
and we get
8x for $5.
Think we can do something with this,
right?
Yeah, this is good.
This one
Where'd it go?
Where'd my stupid box go, man? I just
had it selected.
There's not really a template anymore,
convert, because like it just got
simpler. There's very little now. You
just kind of copy the default MS
and where
Says shitty internet though. This is not
in this data center.
Not terrible. But where'd my other one
go, man?
Just read
now. Somebody rented it. I guess
that's obnoxious. This is why I own my
own hardware so I don't have to deal
with this stupid thing. Uh
I guess we'll just deal with this stupid
thing.
I did not select the eight. I did not
select that. What the [ __ ]
Stupid [ __ ] sight, man.
Oh, wait.
Huh?
Push to 50. I can sweep tomorrow. Yeah,
I wanted to run a big sweep.
There we go.
I think I have keys set up on this.
Maybe
Oh no, I accidentally leaked my public
key on stream, guys.
And I think this should be stable
enough. We'll see.
We also need Don't we need the sweep
config for this crap as well?
We do, right? Cuz it's not in default
yet.
So, we got um
Docker.
We do not have Docker.
Are we in a Docker?
No,
we're in a T-Mox.
Is there um a setup for this on Vast?
I think I did have one, right?
Net hack. We'll use deal open.
this global states.
Yeah, Jonathan. Um, so the simplest
thing to start with would be to just use
the DL open. Longer term, we'll probably
want to modify stuff.
I think that this is the type of thing
where
I don't know. I don't know how bad this
horse is.
This horse is probably very good
actually.
Yes, exactly. local strus. If you can do
that without breaking the game, like
what you should do, um you should pretty
much be able to trace and make sure the
game runs the same with your changes
versus the original uh the original cuz
yeah, that's what you would want to do
ultimately. And in fact, like eventually
we're going to want to make it state
setable as well.
150k lines.
It should be reasonably like it's good
code though, isn't it?
I don't want to like slice it apart with
stupid language models, right? Like this
is not like the Runescape private server
code where it's crap to begin with.
Huh?
What just happened?
Let's see how hard it is to get Puffer
running on Vast.
It's if it's hard, that's on me. So,
like, what idiot uh made it so difficult
to get this running? Oh, wait. It's me.
I'm the idiot.
Okay.
One uh cool side monitor thing.
Yeah, this is why I need um boxes with
better
connectivity.
Download still takes forever here.
It is very weird to me that the state
sets don't just work.
I pretty much just want to get this
sweep set up today, honestly.
I think if we could just get um some
reasonable
results. Oh, yeah. Let me try one thing
real quick.
So, if we just turn this [ __ ] off,
can we get it with full sparsity?
Like if I do this, does it work?
server has to go down over the long
weekend. It's like
annoying.
Whatever. We'll run some little tests
here. I've got a sweep running over here
now.
Why is this
something is wrong here?
Is it stuck somehow?
That wouldn't make any sense. This is
like the most stable thing we have.
All I need is like 0.005
and then we can sweep.
But I don't think we're going to get it
based on Yes.
The ranch that runs in sweeps have
much more consistent
higher scores.
Wait, the branched runs in sweeps
much more consistently higher scores for
breakout.
So, do you have the data from that
sweep? Because
the plot that I would want
here,
I can show you just based on
constellation. And you can do this in
Want to be as well. Um though
constellation is very nice for this. But
like do you see how here for the
environments you have different
environments and then you have uptime
versus PF?
You can do that for both of the ends if
you just have them in separate folders
or on wand just like uptime perf log
scale and that will show whether it's
actually getting a better better results
or like just quicker or what.
Like because ultimately the thing that
we care about is the Purto frontier and
how quickly we're converging to the
Pareto frontier. there.
I'm also a little bit confused on the PR
because like
so carbs was based on Hibo and like
fixed some things with that and then
protein fixed a bunch of things with
carbs.
Like we do have cost awareness in
protein already as well. In fact, we
explicitly like we changed the way that
it does it in carbs because like the way
that they did it was very brittle and
there were a bunch of easy ways to hack
it.
Now, if it is a big difference, I'm very
happy to like to try that thing out.
Um, in fact, I probably should anyways
just like set aside a box. Maybe I'll do
that with this.
I do have an active one now.
1,200 runs default would take too long.
So use more narrow sweep config and
fewer runs.
I see. H
I mean if you have some decent like
starting point stuff, I can run bigger
runs
and try it on more ends.
It's also just a really chunky PR. So,
like if there's a big difference, I'm
very happy to go through and try to
figure things out. Um,
if it's a small difference though, then
basically I have to go rerun it on like
every end.
Why is it reinstalling everything? God
damn it.
I I hate this [ __ ] man. Why can't I
just have my own hardware
thing?
Oh,
that is 98 mining. That is main game.
It's actually going to be much more than
30 hours Volo because I'm thinking of
doing a few hundred,000 um Dale essence.
It makes sense to bank like a few
hundred thousand day, doesn't it?
If you hate RC,
I was thinking of doing what is it?
Aether runes,
cosmic alter.
They give 20 XP each base, so you need
the least amount of day as well. And I
think it's like 130 140k an hour with
dalt and less awful than lavas.
There's a big difference either way,
Volo, because if you consider AFK zero
time, it's onethird of your um it's like
one-third time save
no matter the method.
Yeah, Volo, but like something that's so
AFK I can click it on my side monitor
while I'm working and not even notice
that I'm doing it is like that's
considered zero time.
Plus, I like having something on my side
monitor.
No, it's not. It's I've tried that. It's
really obnoxious. The timings are very
inconsistent.
I think it's the only skill that's just
like slow and there's literally no way
to AFK it at all.
right, we what we're I'm just like sort
of stalling here while this stupid thing
sets itself up. I don't know why it's
installing twice. Um hopefully this
works. We'll see.
I
This is not running more experiments, is
it? All right, hang on. No, is it? Wait.
1 2 3 4 5
Oh, it is running more experiments just
very slowly for some reason.
Huh.
All right. Well, if it's going, it's
going. We'll leave it.
Uh, if you like spending 50 mil an hour,
maybe.
I think it's actually more than that.
Yeah, I think it's 60 m an hour for four
runners.
No, thank you.
That literally wouldn't even be enough
to do it is the crazy thing.
And it's still stupidly high effort. And
that's only about twice as fast as you
doing it yourself efficiently.
Yeah, it's 150 with uh with day alt
which is zero time.
I love paying for 4090s that run slower.
Uh 5090s that run slower than 4090s
because the CPU is [ __ ]
Cool.
You even make money with acers? Yeah,
that's I looked up all the things and
that looked the best to me. Man,
Yeah, I figure all it will be Volo will
be um a few extra days AFK on the way to
99 mining.
And I think you only need to bank like
what is it? 300k of them.
It's way worse with lavas or whatever
cuz you use way more dail Oh,
and I think Aether is like 130 140k an
hour.
31 minutes. That's not bad. Actually,
that's about the same amount of time as
before. I built the wrong end, though.
It's supposed to be boxabun.
There are a bunch of skills where you
have to get to like 90 or whatever
before you can, though.
and there are a few where it's not
really worth it cuz it's literally
onetenth of the XP AFK. Okay.
And I believe sailing you have to get to
84 before you can AFK.
Like it's not even that worth it though
for a lot of them, man.
I mean, the one the obvious one where
it's really worth it is cooking.
All right, this runs. This is fast. I've
successfully stalled long enough talking
about whatever in order for this thing
to be set up correctly.
So, here's going to be the cool thing.
Um, and I hope that this is stable.
I really hope this is stable.
Let me make sure I have this set up
fully.
So, wait. How do I get out of this T-Mox
without
Hang on.
I need to be able to get out of this
T-ox
without it sshing.
How do you get Can you do another team
in here?
Perfect.
Now I can do like this. Python-m pop for
lib
sweep
uh box of bon
8 GPU sweep.
Yeah.
now they're all on.
So take a look at this.
So that is about $6 $6 and change an
hour.
which is still very expensive for um
this type of machine to be fair,
but my machine is down.
Let me add some credits so that I don't
forget um well, let me add some credits
so this doesn't get auto killed because
I need the results off of it. And then I
will just remember tonight to um
yeah, I'll just basically
Add Reddit.
There we go. Put 100 bucks on it.
That should cover this run.
How do I stay focused without
distraction? This is not considered
being focused without distraction.
This is very distracted because at the
moment I keep having all this idle time
while I'm running little experiments and
things, but while I'm deving it's
because I'm actively doing cool [ __ ]
Okay, let me make sure this is not
broken. I really want to make sure that
this thing is nice and stable.
This zero is just it's between
experiments. You'll see. Yeah, see it's
back already.
And then if we just look in logs,
oh actually,
yeah, you can see we already have a
bunch of experiments in here.
Cool.
Is there anything else we can do right
now, guys?
cuz
let me think. I'm a little bit um I'm a
little bit irritated honestly by the
direction stuff has taken. So the
situation right now is we have
incredibly compelling results.
Let me wait for the internet blip just
to pass.
So all right, we have incredibly
compelling results for the base
algorithm
um on an environment where it should
obviously work. And you know, it's like
a very very compelling test, right? It's
on sparse mazes.
And it essentially says that this type
of problem can only be solved by an
algorithm like this.
But then we haven't really been able to
get it to work well on 2048
or Boxabon.
Now we did have an initial sweep some
initial sweep results on 2048 that were
promising.
Um
we that was the case I suppose
and also it's been difficult for us to
run long enough sweeps like this adds an
additional four hyperparameters and
presumably some of the existing
hyperparameters interact with it in a
way that's a little bit hard to learn.
I mean, I think maybe we just get a full
sweep of Boxabon
and uh we see if anything cool comes out
of this
and then if it doesn't, we really are
going to have to start thinking about
some stuff.
How can I develop a research mindset and
how can I approach research by the right
way? I have an article on that. It's not
going to be a super encouraging article,
mind you. Um, but if you actually really
understand and internalize this, it will
save you a lot of time.
The research piece of this,
I'll link it in the chat.
Um, you really really need to pay
attention to the section about the way
that science is done in practice and how
shoddy stuff is.
Like you basically you can't approach
the field as look at all these papers
these tell us what's already been done
these are accurate and like how do I
build on top of like you have to go
looking for where people have gotten
lazy and stuff is broken
and then you have to spot patterns for
where stuff tends to be stupid and
broken and when people are trying to
just push a line of reasoning that
sounds nice but just doesn't work at all
in practice.
A lot of it, a lot of it really just
comes down to understanding the
limitations of the research process as
it is done not by like 20 incorruptible,
you know, perfectly logical scientists
in a white room somewhere, um, but by a
bunch of overworked grad students that
are trying to hack out their next paper.
Look at that. We actually we are already
getting
you see this. We are already getting
some results.
0.019 perfect and score.
Okay, maybe we do just have to sweep it.
Who knows?
Maybe we do just have to sweep it.
2:37.
It is a holiday and I said I was going
to do a shorter stream today.
I'm trying to think if there's anything
else we can do. Take a look at the heo
RP again. Okay, let's actually
the PR appears. Thank you very much. Let
me take a look at this PR.
That's actually very helpful work. Um,
you can feel free to like PR yourself to
the contributor list for this analysis
by the way, regardless of if this gets
merged or not.
Where is this?
Wait. Charts.
Wait, where is
these are? Are new now? I'm confused.
Oh, here.
he gets worse.
Prito.
Yeah, this is worse. Pareto exploration.
Uh, reinforcement learning with robotics
is effective. It's very effective, in
fact. It's just that it's one of those
problems where like you have a lot of IL
data in some cases. And imitation
learning is just much easier to pull off
than um
than reinforcement learning is. Also
reinforce also roboticists have just an
awful reinforcement learning stack. Uh
and I needs basically no stack. So you
see a lot of it.
This is also interesting. Look at this.
It actually
theirs is look at this. This is way
worse sample efficiency compared to
ours.
So ours find found faster and more
sample efficient solutions even though
we're not directly optimizing sample
efficiency.
Now I will say that this cut off here
Those
two sweeps chose to focus on different
horizons.
I see.
Yeah. So, it's not supposed to get stuck
on just one horizon.
That's the point, right?
So, it's quite possible. I mean I
believe there definitely some
improvements that can be made but you
have to be very careful with the
treatment of exploring the parto front
because like this is the curve that you
want. The most important curve in puffer
for experiments is knowing like compute
investment versus best performance
vision language model. No, I don't work
with like I don't work with big chunky
pre-trained models like that. My work
focuses on learning small models from
scratch, incredibly incredibly efficient
simulation and then just like we have
stuff where we can train on decades and
even centuries worth of simulated data
on one GPU from scratch.
Um and I work on mainly fixing core
algorithms, fixing core performance
and uh getting RL to solve problems
where we can simulate stuff fast very
cheaply.
Yeah, this is quite nice analysis though
like this is the exact type of thing we
would like to have.
the dot brightness. Ah, those are later
in the sweep. Yeah, but this so that was
a problem that we had originally, right,
with protein. Like that was one of the
core things that I spent time fixing. So
this unfixes that,
right?
Because look, it's already basically at
one score. So it's spending all this
time trying to improve the score that's
already basically maximum.
Like it's running all these experiments
that are 35 plus seconds. Like this is
not helpful anymore. This is already
solved. We care about pushing this
frontier out this way now, right? Which
is what this one does.
Like the way that um that protein works,
it basically tries to pick a target
cost. It like picks target costs across
the frontier and it tries to run the
best experiment near that cost.
Do you recommend any math book to review
a series of lectures before starting
academic research?
One moment.
Uh, a reading from the gospel of K&R.
C is not a big language and it is not
well served by a big book.
Thus spoke K&R.
Learn some low-level dev. learn some
systems.
Academia doesn't much like systems and
that's why they get nothing done.
No, I actually don't. I got that copy
very recently. Convert. I don't really
read textbooks to be honest with you.
Um, but I did spend quite a bit of time
doing and learning some systems.
This is uh this is nice. Anything else
for me to review today? I'm trying to
think if there's Well, maybe I should
just sort of talk through if there's
anything else I can do. I mean, I've got
the breakout um the other breakout sweep
going.
That's probably not going to do very
much, frankly.
I'm just trying to think on state sets.
Let me just open my um
This was like meh
was meh.
We have a few items at the bottom here.
AMD support PR. How big is it?
Huh?
Wait, why does why is the end has to be
is it like no explicit C implicit cast
or something?
and the D like this doesn't look like um
that doesn't look like AMD support to
me.
Okay, I think that is deterministic.
Do you have any le you have any lectures
or technical videos?
I have lots of pieces of content. If you
look mostly my articles on X, there are
a few videos on the YouTube channel as
well.
They're for different audiences
depending on the content.
Okay. I hate like this is Codeex or
Claude putting crap back in.
Uh,
Yeah, I'm willing to merge this. Um, I'm
willing to merge this if it is slimmed
down substantially.
Uh, doesn't break determinism or any of
our other core stuff and is actually
reasonably efficient on AMD GPUs. Like,
you know, if I can go rent an AMD box
from somewhere or like test this on a
multiGPU AMD box and it's actually
decent, then sure.
And if it's really good, heck, I might
even go buy some one of the AMD some of
the AMD boxes from Tiny.
But you can't like this can't have a
whole bunch of other crap in the PR,
right? Like there's a whole bunch of
other crap now that's like in here.
If you clean that up, then sure.
I see there. It looked like there was a
bunch of other stuff in there, though.
There's also just a lot of weird extra
abstraction
being added to stuff.
Like, I don't know why everything's a
[ __ ] class. That's awful.
Like I don't like it adding it's adding
layers to [ __ ] that where it shouldn't
be adding layers to.
Like for instance,
where is it?
I saw like several things in here that's
just not
Where is it?
All these macro guards are a total pain
in the ass. I like this is the only
place. Well, okay. I actually do
understand the macro guards for this.
Fine.
million little functions that call
oneline functions. This I hate this.
I I'm willing to b like basically I'm
willing to merge support if it doesn't
[ __ ] up the code.
Like we're not like deepening the stack
in order to add AMD support, right?
We're not going to go oh GPU in it and
then there's a backend that's AMD. It's
just like you know if like if ROMC this
otherwise that like Nvidia fine we're
not deepening the stack for sure for
this
know the return types. H man,
I mean it'll be on you to find a way to
do it cleanly pretty much.
I would also want to know if this is
like worth doing, right? Like, can you
even get AMD GPUs on Vast? Is that a
thing?
They have a working website for [ __ ]
sake.
Yeah. So, they don't even have
they don't even have RTX on. I mean,
they don't even have AMD on here.
So, I guess like
who is this for?
Like, okay, it's nice if you have an AMD
laptop, I guess, but like
if we're going to be adding crap to
Puffer Lib, you know, substantial
amounts of crap to Puffer LIIB to
support a laptop, like to support people
with AMD laptops, like
here? You can get a 4080 for 20 cents an
hour
and
3080 is 9 cents an hour, which is what I
have in my box right here.
So, if we're gonna like if it's just for
laptop GPUs when you can literally rent
one for like pennies an hour,
right? I mean the only thing that would
be useful I would say is like they still
sell these
like okay if it's going to be useful for
this like something like this maybe
but I think Tiny is like the only ones
even doing this
so I guess it would Kind of cool to be
able to do Yes.
Oh, hang on. I found the problem with
this.
All right, we're going to try something.
maybe not?
I'll leave it as is for now.
What programming language would you
recommend for AI
Python engineers are just problem
engineers.
I do want to know whether this is
actually exploring [ __ ] don't I?
I could SCP it real quick.
Okay, it is exploring this just not very
much.
So this is fine then, right?
Local struck state version of net hack
is up now. Really?
bindings.
Wait, prompt handling. What?
What prompt handling
Okay, this is a 40 OPR. Makes sense.
Not going to be state setable yet, but
this is still uh
Okay.
Oh, okay. I see
that that type of prompt. Okay, I see.
That's fine then.
So, it looks like you've copied all the
uh the OBS, right?
This is going to probably be mergeable
if you haven't messed with any of our
core stuff.
Um,
wait. Why do we have seconds?
Oh, okay. This is timing. That's fine.
Um, the question is going to be how many
Okay, you do have macros for this stuff.
Yeah. So, the question is going to be
how many of the obs do we actually need?
And like, is there a reasonable way to
represent them without massively blowing
crap up?
the architecture is going to be a little
bit obnoxious, right? Because the
observation space is chars.
Um,
so it's like very heavily a discrete
encoder. There's not really any
reasonable way to do that efficiently.
So, you know, presumably we could just
map it to um like a way lower dim space
presumably.
Okay. Well, I mean, it looks like you've
actually put quite a bit of time into
like going through and thinking about
this, so this is fine.
And this is with DL SIM.
Wait, this is with DL SIM, right?
Yeah. So, I'll merge this as is, man.
Um, what I would like you to do for this
is you should just if you this has
already been done separately for
different ends. You just basically put
this into a one line in the buildsh
that's under um net hack or whatever. So
when people do build shnet hack,
they get this.
Test both options. Yeah, profiler is
good.
Profiler is good. I realized that it was
the C when I saw it.
Wait, something seems off here, right?
Total.
Yeah, these are way. Yeah, lot a lot of
obs here. We got to figure out something
to do with this.
That's why it's slow.
Um, we need to get that hack at least
into the millions.
Have you seen 2S CS231N?
Yes, it's in my articles. If you read my
other article like my how to get into
RL, it's one of the core
recommendations. I took it in person and
um I did research with Justin who was uh
one of their first well was one of the
creators of the course and taught it for
a few years.
Yeah. So, I would ask if you could clean
up a couple of these things. Um,
this should just work with buildsh local
or build fast. Like, we have a we
already have a way to do live views,
interactive play. Like we already have
ways to do this stuff without having to
have per end versions.
Oh, there's a lot of crap in here, isn't
there?
Yeah. But then what you'd basically do
is you would just put all this stuff
into the build command under just like,
you know, if NV is this, you'd add these
flags and it would just go into the
build sh.
And then we have 1 mil full utilization
with double buffering.
4 mil model.
Yeah. So your model's really big here.
And then also the you're going to end up
getting me bound because of how big the
obs are. We got to fix that.
And everybody's PR and cast dispatches
today. Huh.
Oh, wait. You did this already. This is
I This is what I was asking for. It's
already done. Perfect.
Uh, and it looks like the only thing
that isn't done is the
visualizer integration, but otherwise,
this is good.
It's fine. Kernels.
So, just added a kernel, huh?
I miss something.
So, just randomly adds one kernel, but
that's it. I mean, that's fine then.
use. It's going to need some work before
this can be usable, though. Like, this
number's got to go up.
Uh T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T
T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T
T T16 is useless as well. Like this has
to go up. Uh model size got to go down
and probably OB size has to go down is
the really the big one.
This is going to be fun to play with
though.
reasonable threads. Um, it's kind of
just swept per end. Like it's I think
that's in the sweep even
like eight or 16. We don't try we try
not to do 16 when we can avoid it
because if you run a sweep on a multiGPU
machine you're going to run out of cores
Net hack in here is awesome though. Net
hackctor is misconfigured.
Okay, what do I have to do for this?
your building project or software. Could
you explain what you're doing, please?
Yeah. So, um, well, at the moment, I'm
kind of waiting because I have a bunch
of experiments running. Um, I build
Puffer Lib. PufferLib is a very, very
high performance library for
reinforcement learning. It includes a
pure CUDA implementation of our core
learning algorithm. Our core learning
algorithm is the base is just PO but
then it incorporates uh modifications
from a lot of our own research. We have
very high performance environments that
can simulate tens of millions of steps
per second. Training can go up to 20
million steps per second on a single
GPU. Uh we make it pretty easy to add
new environments. And what I'm doing at
the moment is I was merging in a PR from
uh this new uh this contributor here.
Actually, that is Wait. Okay. Yeah, I
was merging in uh this PR. Um
and
this is something that I actually I've
been asking for for a while. So, awesome
to see somebody did it. Uh this is a
binding for Net Hack.
And we're going to get this integrated.
We're going to play around with it a
little bit. And this is just like a
really awesome RL environment that would
be useful for research if we can get it
fast enough. This was kind of the
current distraction. But in the
background here, I've been setting up
today some various experiments on a new
algorithmic feature that we've been
working on, trying to see if the
implementation helps on a couple
different benchmarks.
Um, I've been looking through a couple
of other contributions from people on
different areas of the project and I
kind of just stream all of it.
Haven't seen that one.
Oh, wait. No, you didn't.
Hang on then. What?
Oh, Net Hacker is not
Hang on. This is not a folder.
Yeah, this is not a folder, dude. What
is this?
Okay. If you uh can fix that, that would
be appreciated.
Uh it trains a lot faster than 300k.
Oh, it goes down. I see.
And more time goes into the end.
Do we know how well this thing trains?
Like, do you know what score this thing
gets? Is it any like is it comparable to
anything?
I'm honestly surprised it trains this
fast with those massive obs.
This is using 40 gigs of RAM as well,
which is pretty unheard of for a puffer
envelope
length can change a lot.
Yeah. So, it's probably the resets are
slower or something.
I mean, if you can just run some basic
experiments on this thing and like um
figure out if we can do something with a
subset of the obs or like a small subset
or something. Maybe get us an encoding
that makes some sense. We can sweep this
and we can like this is workable.
Honestly, it's not that far off from
being like puffer level PF. Obviously,
57% end of time sucks, but I think the
end of time now also includes GPU time,
like transfer from N to GPU.
So, this is including transferring the
OBS to the card, I think.
No, don't add an action mask, Jess. Damn
it.
But this is cool.
Let me actually just send a pretty
screenshot of this to um
Let me just friend of mine's going to be
very happy about this.
OBS,
we live
450K on the 5090 is like
reasonable.
Okay, this is sketchy as hell. Why is
the RAM usage going up, man?
Uh,
does your end leak, man?
I'm killing this before it OMs my
desktop and I uh and it takes it
offline.
Look, can you um maybe just check on
some things? H
I will say I've been very I'm very very
happy to see this PR like Net Hack will
be an amazing amazing RL environment,
but it's got to be fast. It's got to be
stable. It's got to have reasonable OBS,
yada yada yada, right?
This will be a huge contribution though
if you're able to polish it up.
I'll be very happy to have it. Like
look, I literally a friend has already
replied
like ah yeah.
Cool.
Anything else I should look at? Let's
see.
We got uh
running. We're good.
replied, "Do you bots
Um, my undergrad at Stanford, PhD is at
MIT.
Yeah, thank you very much for the PRs.
Yeah, I look forward to getting the uh
the fixes.
I think that's everything for the time
being,
right?
We'll leave this one like this.
Got a couple sweeps going.
This I don't want to do till tomorrow.
This is fine.
Yeah, I think the only thing left is
like why aren't we doing better
immediately? Um,
I'm going to have to do some thinking
about the core algorithm
and whether it makes sense to run
ablations on the maze or what.
Hopefully though, we can figure
something reasonable out.
Maybe I need to sweep mazes. Maybe I
need to sweep something else. We'll see.
I think I'm going to call it for today,
though. It is um it is a holiday. It's 5
hour stream is good for that. I'm a bit
tired today as well, so I'll get some
rest.
For folks watching,
um yeah, for folks watching, if you're
new around here, please take a moment to
Star Puffer on GitHub. I know it's one
of those really small things, but it
actually this helps me a ton. Companies
see Puffer because of this and then I
don't have to spend my time advertising
and I get to spend my time here uh doing
dev.
You can join Discord to get involved
with the project. As you see, we have
lots of contributors doing all sorts of
cool things. And you can follow me on X
for more reinforcement learning content.
All my educational articles are there as
well. Share the link buffer.ai AI.